magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman welcome
everybody i want to start today with a
foreign policy situation that is quickly
building and i want to highlight
uh some comments that were made which i
think are sort of the epitome of the
false simplification of the situation in
russia and ukraine now the context here
is we have a genuinely concerning
escalation
in terms of russian aggression or
threatened aggression implied aggression
towards ukraine i think we still don't
really know vladimir putin's true
intentions on the one side once we
consider 130 000 russian troops massing
at the ukrainian border with significant
military equipment and an arsenal of
various weapons we say well putin's
clearly planning to invade and try to
take ukraine
the other side would be putin has no
intention whatsoever of invading and
this is all uh uh either
um
sort of a let's see what happens sort of
thing or even further some say this is
the logical reaction from russia
to the hostilities from ukraine and nato
allies saying maybe maybe maybe
ukraine will at some point become part
of nato which would be very much not to
vladimir putin's advantage now i want to
highlight some comments made by former
i know it's weird to say former
democratic congresswoman tulsi gabbard
and a lot of you will say
she's almost exclusively appearing on
fox and giving pretty reactionary takes
what she she was a democrat when she was
um in the house of representatives i'm
just telling it to you like it is and
what tulsi gabbard says to tucker
carlson is really the epitome
of the false simplification that a
certain
wing and again i i don't even want to
call it a wing of the left because it's
what what views of hers are now really
left but it doesn't matter
this is
a view on russia ukraine
that is really the epitome
of the
russia's the victim not the aggressor
and the u.s is primarily the bad actor
perspective and tulsi also takes it as
an opportunity not only generally to
criticize the united states but also to
criticize joe biden and here's her view
on how we de-escalate
the the russia ukraine situation take a
listen to this
oh first of all
biden president biden could
end this crisis and prevent a war uh
with russia by doing something very
simple guaranteeing that ukraine will
not become a member of nato because if
ukraine became a member of nato that
would put u.s and nato troops directly
on the doorstep of russia which
as putin has laid out would undermine
their national security interests
the reality is that it is highly highly
unlikely that ukraine will ever become a
member of nato anyway so the question is
why doesn't president biden and nato
leaders actually just say that yeah and
guarantee it
tucker loves it this is a this take is
perfect for fox news as you can see now
there's there's two major problems with
this and the reason i'm i'm using
tulsi's comments as an on-ramp to this
is because there's lots of people who
are saying
um
we we're goading the west is goading
ukraine i'm sorry the west is goading
russia by maybe you know flirting with
the possibility that ukraine could
become part of nato and many of them say
a promise was made that that would never
be the case so joe it's joe biden so
there's two issues here first of all is
the the major issue of why can't we just
say
the best way to prevent an escalation is
for the aggressor to stop their
aggression okay i don't want war with
russia i don't want to attack russia i'm
not an imperialist i'm not a warmonger
i'm not any of those things but
we have to be able to say that's the
aggressor and the aggressive action here
is not that
ukraine joining nato hasn't been ruled
out well let's look at the simplest and
most direct form of aggression which is
what putin is doing with troops at the
border we just have to be able to say
what things are that's number one so
it's crazy to think you know tulsi was a
democratic candidate and that she
actually had the support of a few
percent of the democratic primary
electorate and they fell for it and they
supported her and these are these are
her takes but let's dig in a little more
into this nato piece
there's lots of people
like tulsi and others who sometimes kind
of pretend to be on the left but they're
really apologists for authoritarians and
one of the things they love to repeat
about russia ukraine is that there was a
promise made
that nato would stop expansion
and they would rule that ukraine will
there was a promise ukraine will never
be part of nato and
the real source of aggression is
starting to toy
with ukraine being part of nato this is
all based on a lie
there is no such promise and because
this is so prevalent in these
discussions where russia ends up being
defended
at the core of this is a lie
such a promise the promise that ukraine
would never join nato
was initially proposed verbally by the
german and u.s foreign ministries but it
was later rescinded by the heads of
government but bush and coal at the time
and it was never put on the table again
so there is no such promise that has
been codified and why does something so
obscure matter it matters because it
underlines the perspective of many of
these people on the situation
at the time
hans dietrich gentile of germany said
it's certain nato will never have troops
on east german soil
and some other promises that were made
there
but the statement was walked back it was
walked back and no such promises were
ever codified in any way it keeps
getting repeated nato broke its promise
nato is breaking its promise nato would
break its promise the u.s is breaking
its promise there is no such promise and
so the focus should be on the aggressors
and the aggressors here are
putin and russia bigger picture ukraine
is a sovereign nation russia doesn't get
to say
we can legitimately be aggressive
because ukraine wants to join nato if
that's the case and so there are some
bad faith actors tulsi gabbard is one of
them who have sort of
uh manipulated and molded the situation
with lies by omission
uh and the like to create this
completely false narrative and
unfortunately there are some people on
the left that are falling forward so
we're going to continue trying to
make clear what really should be very
very clear
we have been following during our live
streams not so much during the podcast
but during our live streams this trucker
convoy
in canada
which has been um i don't even really
want to call it organizing they've sort
of been demonstrating by blocking roads
and
honking horns
against vaccine mandates
uh heavily related to provincial
canadian government decisions and now
the big thing is that the canadian
truckers are going to come to the us
along with american truckers in order to
protest
joe biden's vaccine mandates and of
course the problem with that is
there really are no such mandates the
the supreme court blocked the biden
mandate so we're going to get to that
but there are people including tucker
carlson who are now rand paul is another
they are starting to lionize these
truckers
as uh heroic freedom fighters against uh
biden's oppressive you know whatever
let's take a listen to tucker here
telling us what's going to be happening
and in that thing tonight a group of
american truckers announced they will
begin a nationwide truck convoy in this
country starting next month
in protest against joe biden's vaccine
mandates right now the problem is that
joe biden's vaccine mandates essentially
do not exist
i mean it's you know it's sort of like
we must protest against the american
lockdowns right what you mean sometimes
people wear masks what lockdowns are you
talking about the supreme court blocked
the biden vaccine mandate for employers
with more than 100 employees in january
it's done
there is no such mandate
not to mention
that it wasn't even really a mandate in
that anybody who didn't want to be
vaccinated could just test instead and
only once a week not once a day the way
fox news is much stricter requirement
put in place
states
are responsible
for implementing their own vaccine
requirements as they so please different
states have put in place different rules
and as a reminder the requirements for
crossing the border you know a big thing
with truckers is oh
we you got to be vaccinated to go to
canada or to come back from canada
whatever um
this is
number one applying in many countries
and it's applying in both directions so
the idea of protesting
bidens
vaccine mandates
is bogus and bizarre this is not really
about vaccine mandates first and
foremost it's about once again
similarly to
the trump riots and trump's threats for
mass protests and all these things it's
about generating unrest which they
believe they can use to their advantage
and there's a few different ways in
which they might do that which we'll
talk about later this week
the other important aspect of this
american truck convoy
that is as usual hypocritical and and
deceptive is
the very same people
blaming biden for the supply chain
issues which are really global supply
chain issues that need to be fixed of
course but they're blaming biden for
them
they are going to do something which
will at least in principle make those
supply and supply chain issues worse
it is not the mandates
that are making the supply chain issues
a problem
there are global economic realities that
are having that impact but
taking all of these truckers who
themselves are responsible for moving
product around and not only taking them
off the road moving product but also
blocking roads
and bridges or whatever they plan to do
that's going to make it more difficult
to move products around the united
states they are going to make worse the
very problem that they are blaming joe
biden for so it doesn't have to do with
vaccine mandates obviously if you
couldn't tell and also remember the
hypocrisy that they claim to be all
about law and order and yet they are
encouraging blocking roads which is
against the law and we can have our
views you know it's a completely
legitimate
uh perspective to defend
that
when it is time to
make an impact you don't protest in the
ways that make everybody comfortable
part of
a
civil disobedience long history of this
is well you're going to do things that
are going to make people uncomfortable
so that they pay attention to you i get
that but what was their view of antifa
blocking roads or black lives matter
blocking roads they were all about law
and order then
and now all of a sudden breaking the law
is justified to protest non-existent
mandates that they claim to be
protesting against so the real concern
at the end of the day is is this going
to lead to more violence and more
insanity in canada although there was a
smattering of white nationalism
anti-semitism and xenophobia within
these protests they were mostly what we
would generally describe as peaceful in
the united states i worry that they
won't be and uh donald trump's continued
escalating rhetoric about oh we're going
to protest this and the biggest protests
ever in all of this kind of coded
language about protests i'm worried
about what's going to happen next month
we will be following it and i'm curious
to hear from you let me know at d pakman
what do you expect as far as this
american version of the canadian truck
convoy uh is concerned what do you
expect to see
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
david pakman show is viewer and listener
funded media we depend on your support
and you can sign up at
joinpacman.com we do an extra show every
single day called the bonus show for our
website members we also provide a
commercial free audio and video feed for
our members and you get access to the
daily show
about six hours earlier than we release
it publicly all of those great benefits
and more are available if you sign up at
joinpacman.com
let's talk a little bit about new claims
relating to the 2020 a presidential
election and i know many of you will say
david it's 15 months
uh it's that was 15 months ago how could
we're still getting new claims and the
answer is that yes we are uh and this
one's particularly important because it
really shows the naivete of many of the
believers in these 2020 big lie type
stories we're going to look at a very
interesting but also kind of vomitous
clip from apparently republican
congressman matt gates who is being
investigated for all sorts of serious
crimes matt gates i guess has a podcast
um on right-wing platform rumble which
the david pakman show now also is on
we're putting you know throwing our hat
in the ring seeing if we can de-program
some people over on rumble and matt
gates interviewed marjorie taylor green
fellow radical republican congresswoman
now marjorie taylor green has previously
made some statements about her husband's
2020 vote but in this clip she straight
up says that her husband's vote was
stolen it was stolen back in 2020
and that um he showed up and they said
mr green sir
you've already voted and uh let's just
listen to her story this will be new i i
assume to most of you because she's
never told the story
in this particular way ever before even
though it's been 15 months since the
election we will get criticism after
this episode airs i could care less
by the way remember it's i couldn't care
less and i don't know some of you wrote
to me and you said no
there is a longer version of the phrase
in which it was i could care less
sarcastically okay
uh the the phrase now is i couldn't care
less and i i know i must point that out
it's very important finish the sentence
but i totally get the energy um we will
get criticism because we are making
famous the people in georgia who i think
are able to perpetrate fraud based on
their anonymity they should be famous
they should be famous and i honestly
think in all of you know my husband's
vote was stolen
tell me about it so perry goes to go
vote in the general election and he goes
in person because we don't do absentee
ballots we never requested one we will
not take part in it he goes in person
he's really excited to go vote for me
for congress and vote for president
trump and and vote republican he shows
up and they say mr greene
you've already voted by absentee ballot
he was shocked this was in in november
for the 2020 election he goes no i have
not voted absentee ballot i never even
ordered one and they said yeah we have
it right here and it showed on the
screen that he'd already voted absentee
ballot he had to go through the this
45-minute process
signing all these waivers proving you
know
this you know a statement saying he had
not voted before they let him go
cast his vote electronically
and and actually vote in person so but
guess what there was no no one told him
that they would find the fake ballot
right that supposedly someone cast in
his name by absentee and no one said we
can get rid of that and tear it up now
there is no actual proof that anybody
did submit that we don't even know
assuming what she's saying is true
we don't know where it was merely a
clerical error we just don't know and
the other important thing is that the
story that she told was different
back in november of 2020. the atlanta
journal constitution covered this in an
article called green falsely claims
husband's voting record reveals a scam
she tweeted at the time now we can't go
back and look at the original tweet
because she's been banned from twitter
for spreading weaponized covet
disinformation but at the time she wrote
georgia election scam
my husband never requested an absentee
ballot but when he went to vote they
told him he had all they had already
received his absentee ballot but he
never requested an absentee ballot nor
did he send one in
green posted a screenshot of perry
green's voter information showing her
husband voted early on october 23rd and
that the vote was accepted the screen
also shows a second ballot requested and
received the same day was cancelled
what really happened to the other ballot
now understand that there now we have
two now we have a story of two early
ballots which she didn't just mention to
matt gates
uh robert brady the chief clerk of
elections from floyd county said nothing
happened um the ballot was canceled
according to procedure
according to this he signed an affidavit
on the 23rd of october and was allowed
to vote he only voted once
um
trump questioned this as well
uh also relevant to the marjorie taylor
green thing green began tweeting about
her husband's ballot sunday by monday it
had been retweeted more than 7 000 times
brady the floyd election official said
he couldn't tell from the information
available monday if per monday if perry
green had actually been sent a ballot or
if it was a data entry error but either
way the poll worker followed the correct
procedure by canceling the application
asking the voter to sign an affidavit
and then providing a fresh ballot that
in-person ballot was accepted
um once this shows him as having cast
the ballot it wouldn't matter if we got
25 more we are not going to take any
more of them because we know there
aren't more ballots in play so it's all
super confusing and she also said that
this happened in november
but
it's unclear like all of this might have
happened in october in which case why
did she say it happened in november it's
all bizarre
it's all confusing and this is actually
a very trumpian strategy which is sort
of like televersion tell every version
of any particular story my husband's
vote was stolen uh he got two ballots
now he got one we went in in person in
november well the record shows you went
in in october well it doesn't matter it
was definitely stolen and we've got to
fix it and of course at the end of the
day it's all more or less a red herring
because in regardless of what happened
only one of perry green's potentially
multiple votes was counted meaning the
system worked correctly
number two it wouldn't have made a
difference in the state of georgia and
number three even if it had made a
difference in the state of georgia it
wouldn't have made a difference in the
united states that doesn't mean we don't
care about supposed irregularities and
again this is only a supposed
irregularity because marjorie taylor
green's story is so convoluted we don't
even really know which version she
alleges to be true doesn't mean we don't
care about irregularities but when we
say are elections more or less working
when it comes to the logistics of voting
one question would be
would the alleged irregularities that
have been actually reported in a proper
way not trump vaguely mentioning they
lost a hundred thousand votes there's no
evidence for that but are the actual
reported irregularities
even a fraction of the margin in any
state the answer is of course no
and that's what we really mean when we
say can we generally speaking trust the
results now separately and this is why
there's a sort of projection from the
right on this separately
there's the question of did everybody
who intended to vote
uh actually vote when we talk about the
voter suppression techniques limiting
voting hours
purging people from voter rolls
involuntary stuff like that and that's a
different story but it's important to
understand that while the right claims
the problem is stuff like this well they
just deleted a hundred thousand votes no
that doesn't appear to be the problem
the real issue are the concerted voter
suppression tactics that we've been
covering for what close to 15 years or
something like that so yet another story
from marjory taylor green that just
doesn't really quite make sense i want
to go to something absolutely
fascinating you know
um in all of this discussion in the last
month about mike pence could have
mike pence should have mike pence had a
duty to overturn the 2020 presidential
election results and of course he didn't
have that ability and he certainly
didn't have the duty to do it one of the
things that is increasingly being
mentioned is well if mike pence could
effectively choose the winner
of an election then that means kamala
harris could do the same thing in 2024
kamala harris could decide who wins
understanding that it's not just she
says i award the presidency to whoever
by strategically choosing to reject the
ballots from certain states and send
them back for an alternative slate of
electors you guys understand it's a
little bit more nuanced than just the
vice president chooses well donald trump
uh former donald trump economic adviser
peter navarro appeared on msnbc and was
interviewed by ari melber and this is
really good because ari melber just says
to him well i mean if pence could do it
then kamala harris could do it right
and uh peter navarro twists himself into
an incredible pretzel
to put a final note on this section yes
it would follow from your contention
that you think
vice president harris will ultimately
have the call over who should be
president regardless of the results in
the next election
see you you misconstrued the whole green
bay suite plan it's not for the vice
president to determine who wins okay the
only thing that prince had the authority
to do
is go back to the states and let the
states look at the votes it's the states
in our constitution who have the right
to decide who won an election but you're
not asking but which states were they
that he had the right to do that with
and on what basis was he going to say
i'm sending this back to the states
because remember all the legal
challenges that were filed at the state
levels were found to be without merit
bring the question and it seems like a
question when you put it on harris makes
you peter to ask for a second yeah it
seems like it makes you but it seems
like it's making you stretch when we
just change the name from pence to
harris are you no no no no no holding
the contention let me finish the
question you'll get your response peter
let me finish the question authority to
change the election results
that was not the premise of our argument
are you so under your pressure
a second look
right so let's say that
under your contention vice president
harris could take any states that her
side lost and selectively send those
back that's your current contention
if if
any any vice president
under the electoral account act of 1887
we'll get to that act by the way if
there are objections that are raised
about estates electors the
provision is that you have two hours of
that now the problem with this if there
are objections raised
they raised objections without merit
only in certain states so of course if
the shoe were on the other foot
and kamala harris said well you know
what we have objections that have been
raised in florida and ohio and i'm going
to send them back people like peter
navarro would be out there saying but
those objections aren't legitimate and
that's the issue because he says well if
objections have been raised the vice
president can say we're sending it back
and i don't know in arizona their plan
was to just say we're going to send you
republican electors
the question is who determines the
legitimacy of those objections and none
of the objections raised by these
trumpists in arizona or michigan or
wherever were found to have any merit
now i want to mention one other piece
he says the electoral count act of 1887.
the electoral account act of 1887 was
put in place because nine years prior
there was a disputed election and it
took nine years and they put together
this act in 1887.
it puts the onus of solving disputes on
the states it doesn't say that if there
is a state dispute the vp can say we're
sending arizona back
send us the republican electors that was
their plan the electoral count act is
very narrow and these trumpists don't
care now you go to the rallies and they
repeat it electoral count act of 1887
the electoral count act of 1887 says
if there is a dispute like for example
in arizona
the vice president could say we're gonna
send this back
to resolve the dispute in the state
but the disputes that the trump people
put together in places like arizona were
found to be without merit you don't get
to say well there is a dispute so we're
gonna ignore the nine or however seven
electoral votes for biden from arizona
and instead will accept seven electoral
votes for trump that's not how it works
and
the entire framing of what that
electoral count act did
is being completely bastardized by these
people you probably know that so
not surprising when confronted with well
if pence could get to pick doesn't
kamala get to pick he says well it
depends on whether there are disputes
right but who decides if the dispute is
legitimate well they do
apparently they do and mike pence was
supposed to decide that we'll have this
clip on our instagram if you've just
been listening today find us on
instagram at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
seemingly not a single day goes by that
the crisis of information handling under
the former administration is exposed at
being even worse than we imagined and
remember the backstory and the framing
here hillary clinton in 2015 and 2016.
we were told cannot be president we
can't trust her as president why well
private email
uh improper handling of secret
information sensitive information she's
just not trustworthy and then what did
we have yeah trump spills secrets to a
russian spy recruiter in the oval office
and oh trump's family ivanka and jared
kushner using private email for white
house business oh no
and then trump's ripping up presidential
records in the in the white house and
people are running in and trying to tape
them together
um trump is sending documents in burn
bags to the pentagon to be incinerated
but hillary we couldn't have trusted and
then we find out trump was flushing
documents down the white house toilet it
was getting clogged and staff was having
to come in to you know start uh plunging
away to try to unclog trump's toilet
from all the documents and then the
national archives has had to go to
mar-a-lago
to take back documents from trump that
he improperly took
from the white house and it turns out
now that it wasn't just documents
generically that are at the heart of
this mishandling crisis involving donald
trump
we now know
guys that this includes classified
and documents marked as top secret
there is a new explosive report from the
washington post
some trump records taken to mar-a-lago
clearly marked as classified
including documents at top secret level
this was not previously reported
washington post writes
some of the white house documents that
donald trump improperly took to
mar-a-lago were clearly marked as
classified including documents at the
top secret level
this is according to two people familiar
with the matter
the existence of clearly marked
classified documents in the trove which
has not been previously reported is
likely to intensify the legal pressure
that trump or his staffers could face
and raises new questions about why the
materials were taken out of the white
house it was unclear how many classified
documents were among those received by
the national archives some bore markings
that the information was extremely
sensitive and would be limited to a
small group of officials with authority
to view such highly classified
information the documents were just
sitting around at mar-a-lago guys the
markings were discovered by the national
archives which last month arranged to
collect 15 boxes from trump's residence
archive officials asked the justice
department to look into this though as
of thursday afternoon fbi agents had yet
to review the material
it remained unclear whether the justice
department would launch a full-fledged
investigation the files were being
stored in a sensitive compartmented
information facility while justice
department officials debate how to
proceed
like others uh in this story the people
spoke on the condition of anonymity to
discuss a potentially sense politically
sensitive matter now the trump position
on this is according to spokesman taylor
budowicz it's clear that a normal and
routine process is being weaponized by
anonymous politically motivated
government sources to peddle fake news
no
no the president taking top secret
documents to his house after no longer
being president
is not a routine matter
it is not a routine matter and uh
remember again that when we think back
to the clinton era bill clinton now i
mentioned this last week
bill clinton had a national security
adviser named sandy berger
sandy took four documents that he was
not supposed to have in his possession
uh independently of uh you know where
they were supposed to be stored sandy
burger was fined fifty thousand dollars
he was given years of probation and he
lost his license to practice law
is there no point at which there would
be consequences for this and there's
also another question which is why did
donald trump even do this like i i
trump's not really a sentimental guy
so it's hard to imagine that he took
top-secret documents for sentimental
reasons was he maybe thinking of
these documents as being in his hands as
protecting him in some way it's mere
speculation
diddy i mean being trump did he think
maybe he could sell these documents for
money at some point like it's all
bizarre and remember that the base of
all of trump's campaign against hillary
clinton back in 2016
and even possibly what put him over the
top thanks to james comey's second press
conference about hillary clinton's
emails the whole premise was hillary
can't be trusted with sensitive
information
does anybody believe for a second
that hillary
would be flushing documents down her
toilet
clogging it and then calling down to
maintenance saying bring the plunger
i've clogged the toilet with documents
again give me a break guys give me a
break and this was the main reason we
weren't supposed to vote for hillary
clinton
will there be consequences i don't know
jamie raskin believes there will be and
we'll cover that story later on this
week uh i remain very very skeptical
okay donald trump spent the weekend
delivering these febrile unhinged
interviews to a number of different
media outlets including fox news and
others and some of these are fascinating
in that trump reveals
his retrospective view of his presidency
and it's bizarre and we're going to get
to that first and foremost just to kind
of like get some some business out of
the way trump asked about the story that
he was flushing documents down the
toilet he says it's not true and that
there's no way maggie haberman who is
breaking that story
would know if it were here's trump it's
a totally false story she made it up i
don't believe they have sources who's
going to be a source for that anyway who
would know that uh there's no source
they make it up white house staff who
admit
we were called up to unclog trump's
toilet and it appeared that what was in
there was was paper documents with with
stuff written on it
you know they they often times these
fake writers like her
they they act like they know me like she
knows we haven't spoken her in
a very very long time you know i think
there are criticisms to be made of
maggie haberman one such criticism would
be
if she knew for a while that trump was
power flushing documents down his toilet
you could say she had a duty
to expose that
before being able to monetize it in a
book this is not a criticism unique to
maggie haberman many of these people
hold the most insane stuff they know for
a book on which they make money that
would be a criticism but maggie hamerman
does not have a track record of making
stuff up or making up sources which
would be an incredibly serious thing to
do as a new york times reporter must be
no better than any other writer but they
write books like they know and then they
make things like that up
and uh there would be no way of her
knowing if it were the facts there would
be no way of her understanding that her
knowing it well she claims to and she uh
has a certainly much more honest track
record than does donald trump so donald
trump then going from fox news over to
the usa radio network where he was
interviewed by wayne allen root
wayne allen root has been a guest on
this show many times and wayne allen
root has been one of the guys saying if
republicans take the house in november
make trump the speaker remember you
don't have to be a member of the house
to be made speaker they can vote for
anybody and trump could be made speaker
of the house wayne allen root asks trump
is this something you would think about
and here's the wild and wacky answer the
idea why can't after we win back the
house you become speaker of the house
even for a short period just until we
can
open investigations against biden and
the biden crime family
well i think a lot of things are
happening and a lot of very positive
things are happening and you know when
you look into the future and that was
your idea i heard it from you first i
don't know it certainly has been going
around
and frankly
i hope we don't need it because what
should happen is
what the plan that we're on now and i
think a plan that's going to make people
very very happy we'll be announcing
sometime later
and that's really what should happen
but now of course is he is he alluding
to we're going to announce that i'm
going to run we still don't know we just
we just aren't sure but everything's
always just around the corner with
donald trump and certainly not ruling
out the idea of him being speaker of the
house now uh beyond parody back to fox
news
uh trump making a very confusing and
dishonest claim about the the wall the
infamous wall we were two and a half
three weeks away from think of it
finishing the wall
which is largely frankly finished anyway
it's a tremendous help right we were two
so so consider that
we were two to three weeks from
finishing the entire wall with the u.s
mexico border that's untrue it's a
complete and total lie there is no wall
on the vast majority of the border they
were not about to finish it but then he
says and quite frankly it was finished
well
why did you need two to three weeks to
finish it
if it's finished and and of course then
the real
policy question is
if you finished the wall
why isn't it stopping people from coming
over which trump claims are are coming
over in record numbers under joe biden
if the wall is there how is it how isn't
it working it's all very very strange
now here's the wacky this is the most
delusional part of the entire interview
trump describes his presidency
as being a glamorous time in american
history and a romantic period he
imagines his presidency was like an
episode of downton abbey
just the numbers our country was
thriving we were just beating everybody
and by the way charging china massive
taxes and tariffs taking in hundreds of
billions of dollars we never took in
guys he's he still doesn't understand
how tariffs work you guys know this
right like when trump says we were
charging china tariffs
and taking in money from china that's
not the way it works the tariffs are
paid by the american companies importing
the chinese goods if i need steel to
build i'm an american company and you
put a tariff on chinese steel
i pay china for the steel the chinese
company for the steel
and then i pay a tariff to the u.s
government
it's the american companies that pay the
tariffs he still doesn't appear to get
it okay but let's continue ten cents and
they viewed it as a romantic period i
think and i think that's really why it's
doing so well because there is a lot of
romance to the book it was despite all
of the
vicious hoaxes and and scams that they
pulled and made up stories like russia
russia russia you know you had the
mueller you had impeachment hoax number
one impeachment hoax number two despite
all of that they viewed as a very
glamorous time because our country was
doing so well this this is so
i get that trump is like you know seeing
himself as some kind of uh
[Laughter]
elizabethan um uh
leader during a romantic
it's all bizarre and it's it's
empirically untrue
the reputation of the u.s under trump
was i i know that with trump this is can
be literal it was in the toilet
uh you know he had ted nugent in the
oval office not exactly the pinnacle of
glamour or romanticism um but but of
course the u.s was widely seen as the
global laughing stock under trump okay
one last clip from this unhinged series
of interviews trump rounding out his
media tour this weekend by spreading
mass disinformation and everybody says
that the mask for the new variant at
least
is virtually ineffective i mean totally
ineffective why so i don't know what
they're doing and why they're doing it
but they've come out and said that the
mask has almost no impact especially on
the new variant and now that's of course
untrue
uh what we have found out is that due to
how contagious omicron is
you really want to be wearing a properly
fitted n95 kn95 i think there's the kf
94 or something you know you want a
properly fitting good mask wearing one
of those gators or as i once saw a woman
do on a plane cover her face with a
paper towel to walk to the bathroom you
don't want to be doing that you want to
be wearing a proper actual protective
mask so
really very dangerous and weaponized
disinformation being spread by trump but
fundamentally still repeating all of the
same lies he's been repeating and
there's there's a whole network of
places where he's allowed to do it he
goes on oan he goes on newsmax fox news
the wayne allen root show wherever he's
uh accepting interviews other than that
recent npr interview where he was
actually confronted and hung up the
phone
he is welcomed and allowed to spread all
of this stuff and that should really
concern all of us because there is still
a very willing audience
extraordinarily receptive to the lies
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show you guys know that any
opportunity to uh explain a uh an
economics concept or a behavioral
economics concept i i welcome those
opportunities on the show and today i
have that opportunity thanks to an
anti-vaccine leader who has repented an
anti-vaccine leader who was completely
committed to their anti-vaccine activism
but has now changed their mind and
admits
that the anti-vaxxers have deaths on
their consciences if not on their hands
um this is a very interesting story and
there's a lot to say about it as
newsweek reports
anti-vaccine speaker pasquale bacco
repents
after one of his fans has died of kovid
unvaccinated and we'll talk a little bit
about when it becomes personal
uh an italian anti-vaccine speaker has
expressed remorse about his actions
after he discovered that a follower of
his who died of covid had videos on his
cell phone of speeches that he made
pasquale bacco is a doctor
who was a prominent anti-vaxx activist
in italy taking part in numerous rallies
and events
but now bacco who has more than 7 000
followers on facebook said he was a
believer in the effectiveness of
vaccines
when asked by the interviewer what
changed his mind bacco talked about an
incident in which he saw a 29 year old
man die of covet quote he had on his
mobile phone
the videos of my rallies at the
demonstrations of the unvaccinated the
family told me he was a fan of mine they
didn't tell me with anger on the
contrary and this hurt me even more i
feel like that death was my fault
and the thing still bothers me today for
it was not a creed when i saw the
reality of my own eyes with my own eyes
i realized that i was wrong
asked whether he felt guilty about his
actions baco said i think that those of
us who went up on those stages
have deaths on our conscience
all of us anti-vaccine activists have
been great cowards we went to the
squares and when we spoke we knew that
people wanted to hear shocking things so
you provoke more and more
we were really big bastards i don't hide
it that's the truth for this i have
asked for forgiveness from everyone but
that forgiveness is useful he spoke at
around 300 anti-vaxx protests and was
the only young doctor with experience
among the speakers and he now recognizes
the destructive power of being a doctor
at these events he said quote what i
said was pure gold for people who were
afraid and looking for certainty you
don't realize you were losing your
rationality you lose your mind while
being a rational person at that moment a
dangerous process takes place that
anti-vaxx is a faith and you become a
god you enter absolute madness the
anti-vaxxers are people who were afraid
and find security in you
so many important things here number one
for years i have been talking about this
phenomenon
wherein
part of what makes conspiracy theories
and conspiratorial thinking attractive
is that it provides certainty in an
uncertain world and that applies here
and i'll explain it in very clear terms
well let me give an analogy first and
then i'll explain
what what this is
why is it that to some people it's
appealing when there is a horrible mass
shooting that kills 20 kids i won't even
say the name of it because then the
video will get demonetized or limited
there's a mass shooting and 20 kids die
and some people come out and they say
it was a false flag planned event
with crisis actors
meant
to
create fear
to justify taking people's guns why why
do they say that because the truth is
really scary the truth is uncertain
the truth is
kids are mostly safe in school
but
sometimes
seemingly randomly you might say well
we're in nebraska so it won't happen
here or we're in connecticut it won't
happen here
randomly these horrible things happen
and your kid is killed
and that uncertainty is really difficult
for many people to accept and so it's
more in a sense comforting to believe
there's no randomness here this was a
planned event now it ignores that the
event could be planned at your kid's
school or someone else's school but it
gives you a sense that there's not this
random unpredictable nature to the world
similarly it's really stressful to them
to believe well there's a virus and most
people are okay but a bunch of people
die and sometimes who dies is
unpredictable could it be me or maybe
not and there's this vaccine which it's
mostly effective at preventing people
from dying but it's a bell curve
distribution and every once in a while
there will be people who are fully
vaccinated and they die so it's simpler
to believe
the vaccines just don't work they're
evil tools they are meant to control
people or microchipper they they would
rather that it's all planned it's all
planned rather than
vaccine probably will protect you but it
might not and the virus probably won't
kill you but it might and it could be
your parent or child or would
and that is exactly what pasquale baco
is picking up on here when he says the
certainty
of the anti-vaxx stuff particularly
hearing it from a doctor is so important
now do we like forgive this guy it
doesn't even really matter i mean it's
not it's not about forgiving or whatever
the case is one other thing that's at pr
at pray here at play rather is don't
fall prey to the sunk cost fallacy
you're always better off coming around
and turning back to sanity and a lot of
people like this guy because they feel
like i'm really committed to this
anti-vac stuff i'm too far gone i'm not
turning around you can always come back
and the sunk cost fallacy a couple of
examples are you buy a ticket to a movie
to two hour movie and after an hour and
15 minutes you're like this is the worst
movie i've ever seen but i already paid
so i might as well stay
if you could better use those last 45
minutes to do something more enjoyable
than watch the crappy movie you've paid
for the ticket either way you shouldn't
stay because you've already sunk a cost
into that movie you get out and you
enjoy the last 45 minutes doing
something else that's the sunk cost
fallacy another one is you know you go
to a casino
and you lose 80 of your money and you
stop having fun but you figure well i
lost 80 of the money i might as well
keep playing now you don't have to keep
playing and lose all of it just walk
away and go do something that's more fun
so that's the sunk cost fallacy good for
pasquale here not falling forward and
saying as far gone as i am i'm gonna
turn around and that's exactly what he
did and you know i i'm not even saying
he should be forgiven or not but very
interesting commentary from this guy
uh okay this is now just uh
it's
it's sad
that it has gotten to this point
donald trump has suggested
that at times past it would have been
appropriate to put some hillary clinton
operatives to death
to death to kill them
um there is a uh supposed spying
operation
um there's a court filing that happened
last week
which i'll mention briefly and it almost
like doesn't really matter what the
facts are but i'll mention
that last week it was alleged by special
counsel john durham that clinton
campaign lawyer michael sussman paid
tech companies and researchers to mine
internet data to establish an inference
and narrative tying trump to russia this
was reported by fox news and the right
became absolutely titillated by it trump
put out a statement
saying
the latest pleading from special counsel
robert durham provides indisputable
evidence that my campaign and presidency
were spied on by operatives paid by the
hillary clinton campaign in an effort to
develop a completely fabricated
connection to russia by the way even if
true that's not what the allegations uh
exposed but okay
trump goes on to say
this is a scandal far greater in scope
and magnitude than watergate that's not
true and those who were involved in and
knew about this spying operation should
be subject to criminal prosecution
in a stronger period of time in our
country this crime would have been
punishable by death
in addition reparations should be paid
to those in our country who have been
damaged by this
i would say at what point do we have to
say this isn't funny anymore but the
thing is we said that the day after
trump was elected in 2016.
it's now even
more not funny
it's hard to even know what words to
apply to this are there no consequences
for threatening violence as long as
you're in a position of power and have
money
something is very very wrong here
something is wrong that we have so many
people that hear this and they say
trump's right
go on
the right-wing enclaves go on the
right-wing subreddits check out rumble
where i'm now you know paying attention
now that we're putting our content up
there and people hear trump say this and
they say he's right
these people should be put to death
they've not been even charged with any
crime never mind convicted it's not even
clear they did anything illegal
uh but they're there it's not it's not
just that trump is saying they should be
put to death there's a contingent of the
country that says they should be killed
and uh something is also very wrong
that there are never any repercussions
for any of this stuff if you're in a
position of power of course
absolutely
incredible and the fear is i mean listen
you guys know what the fear is right
no repercussions for any of these people
we already saw how effectively trump can
incite a riot
we already heard from trump at his
recent rallies
we're going to have even bigger protests
if they charge me with anything if these
investigations lead we will have the
biggest protest
which is again trump alluding to his
supporters doing violence his supporters
seem ready to do more violence
and
we should be scared
we should be scared and i try never to
be hyperbolic here
uh
but at this point
i'm very worried about what the next
eight and a half months leading up to
the midterms will look like and then
depending on what happens in the
midterms depending if republicans take
over
what is going to happen in the lead up
to the 2024 election very very scary we
have a voicemail number and that number
is 2192 2192davidp
you can leave a voicemail about anything
here is a voicemail that was left
pointing out the continued so-called
free speech confusion that many on the
right are experiencing take a listen to
this
david why do conservatives constantly
cry about free speech but they never
seem to realize that that only applies
to what the federal government does why
don't they just argue for amending the
constitution to apply those same rules
to private companies well because they
don't necessarily know that yeah so this
is a very important thing um
free speech is sometimes used
colloquially just to say
me saying whatever i want wherever i
want with no consequences and nobody
having an ability to limit what i'm
allowed to say now of course when you're
on a platform that has terms of service
and you're not being discriminated
against because of your race or religion
or whatever the platform can enforce
terms of service and this is a good
point that when we talk about the first
amendment
we are talking about government limiting
speech does the bulk of the right wing
realize that when we talk about my first
amendment right to free speech it
doesn't apply to twitter
some of them might but many of them
don't
but the next question is a good one
why don't they just say
first amendment rights should apply
to private companies of all kinds and
the reason some of them don't do it is
because they don't even understand what
we're talking about okay put those aside
the reason
more prominent republicans
don't suggest that
is they realize that it actually is a
dangerous slippery slope you know i i
make a point
to signal
when the fear of a slippery slope is is
unwarranted there's lots for example
they would say oh the vaccine mandates
are going to open the door to
what all sorts of authoritarianism it
hasn't happened we've had vaccine
requirements in this country for a
hundred years and even when it comes to
the covet vaccine mandates they've
mostly been relaxed the supreme court
said no to biden it was a there was no
slippery slope there there just
historically we knew there wouldn't be
common sense we knew there wouldn't be
when it comes to this entire absolute
free speech applied to all companies
period
it actually would be a crazy slippery
slope when it comes to an employer's
ability to limit uh workers from
speaking
customers
it it would actually be an insanely
heavy-handed form of the regulation of
businesses and many republicans realize
that and that's why they will vaguely
say oh you know we've got a
conservatives got to make sure that we
have a voice on platforms and whatever
but they typically stop short of that
extremely authoritarian at the end of
the day claim or request
that free speech should apply to any
private company the way it does to the
government because they understand the
very serious repercussions and they
understand it would be completely
counter to their view of let businesses
do what they want to do as long as it's
not against the law and sometimes even
if it is
many republicans know that smarter
republicans recognize that and that's
why they don't say let's regulate
companies in the exact same way when it
comes to speech as the government is
regulated by the first amendment we have
a great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the super bowl halftime show
i have a number of different thoughts
about it congressional staffers are
organizing a union we will tell you why
and whether it's likely to succeed and
we will talk about the latest in the
sarah palin new york times defamation
case it's getting very interesting make
sure you sign up
now really at joinpacman.com
and get instant access to the bonus chef
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors magic spoon
tastes exactly like your favorite
childhood breakfast cereals but it has
no sugar lots of protein it's keto and
low carb friendly it's delicious without
the guilt get five dollars off when you
click my link below and use the promo
code pacman